biden's got this build back better thing
we all know they tried to pass this
thing 3.5 trillion dollars equals zero
math doesn't matter anymore it has
almost nothing to do with infrastructure
but now everything's infrastructure uh
we've got some info here from the daily
wire
president joe biden debuted an updated
version of his build back better
spending plan this time scaled back from
the 3.5 trillion human infrastructure
plan proposed months ago in hopes that a
fractured democratic party can unite
behind both this and the bipartisan
physical infrastructure bill uh the
language
they reintrodu the reintroduced bill
comes on the heels of a string of white
house failures and selling a more
ambitious build back better spending
bill which would have spent double the
new 1.7 trillion compromise package
progressives were not willing to back a
bipartisan infrastructure bill without a
guarantee that ex the expansive spending
measure would pass the senate and key
senators were not willing to back the
expansive spending bill without major
cuts i mean of course the hilarity here
really is that if 3.5 trillion dollars
actually equals zero then what does
1.75 trillion equal and what is it that
we can't get done at that point sean you
have a little insight in how the
messaging comes out of it administration
how did they do here
i think build back better is now scaled
back worse i mean that that should just
you still have close to two trillion
dollars that comes on the heels of three
trillion that we spent earlier this year
i mean i just read this morning that
they can't account this is from
propublica a left-leaning organization
they don't they can't account for the
money they sent to schools we know that
the money set aside for rental and
mortgage assistance 40 billion of 49
billion hasn't been used or discovered
this is they are literally creating a
price tag and then working backwards
figuring out how much to spend the idea
that 2
trillion dollars trillion trillion
trillion is scaling things back
i don't this is what world are we living
in where this is happening but dave here
is my
strategy for every republican i said it
on the show last night to congresswoman
kat kamik and i'll say it out here now
every republican needs to just say the
following we are in the minority we have
no say in this you will pass whatever
bill you want so here's what i would ask
of you speaker pelosi let your own
members read it
give them enough time because that's my
challenge name one member of congress
that can actually say at the time that
they vote for it that they actually have
read it there is no physical way that
they will have done that
liz is that it that this is just all
just like a nonsensical shell game not
that
whether it's 3.5 trillion or 1.5 that's
almost irrelevant nobody's read it
that's almost irrelevant they are just
doing anything under the guise of we're
trying to help you because we've wrecked
everything well they don't tell you that
we've wrecked everything but that's
really what's going on here they're
wrecking everything so in essence they
can just get more of our money it's as
simple as that
yeah i mean i never thought i'd say this
before and i'll probably never say this
again but i really appreciate
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and congresswoman ilhan omar and all of
these progressives derailing this
because the longer we can prevent this
from being imposed on the american
people the better for us all i mean
they're using they're using this
strategy that dave you and i and several
other conservative commentators
identified a long time ago where they
take the idea of an emergency and they
use this idea of emergency to instill
fear in people and then when people are
crippled with fear and hysteria they say
we'll be your saviors we'll rescue you
if only you let us have control and a
lot of people in their fear in this
facing what they think is an emergency
they hand over their rights and their
freedoms and their and even some
privileges and control and power and the
government under joe biden in his
radical administration sean is exactly
right to name his book radical nation
under this radical administration they
are not going to stop trying to take our
rights and our liberties and power and
freedom until we say enough and stop
letting them do it and this this bill is
just another example i mean it's rife
with their agenda climate change and
abortion and taxes on the rich and
crippling the economy and all kinds of
stuff that hurt everyday americans that
will cause the price of goods to go up
and our wages to go down cause jobs to
be scarcer cause all kinds of
ramifications that the liberal elite in
washington dc won't feel but you and i
will look i want to say one quick thing
that everyone needs to understand is
crucial and this is the point that i
make in the book whether it's the
spending making dc state passing or
packing the court letting
folks flow over illegally our southern
border federalizing elections every
single thing is in pursuit of permanent
political power it all ties together
it's not about a policy it's about how
much money can we get out of the
government to people to get them
addicted it's allowed voting rights it's
not it's it's about creating people who
will keep them in power it's about
creating a state that will give them two
democratic senators everything that the
left is doing right now is in pursuit of
permanent political power and that is
crucial to understanding everything that
they do in their motives